Welcome back.
I shouldn't try to squeeze in
videos because then I rush,
and then you won't learn, and
everything breaks down.
So problem number 7, a, b, and
c are different positive
integers, and 2 to the a times 2
to the b times 2 to the c is
equal to 64.
They want to know what is 2
to the a plus 2 to the b
plus 2 to the c?
Well, here two things
we can use.
We can use our exponent rules
where if we have the same base
and we multiply it we can
just add the exponents.
So this is equal to 2 to
the a plus b plus c.
Then, can we write 64
as a power of 2?
Sure.
Let's see, 2 to the
third is equal to
8 and 64 is 8 squared.
So if we square both sides of
that, that's 2 to the sixth.
You might already know that,
2 to the sixth is 64.
You could think of it as
2 to the fifth is 32.
2 to the sixth is
64, of course.
So a plus b plus c
has to equal 6.
What do they tell us?
a, b and c are different
positive integers.
So what are a, b and c?
Well let's see, they could
be 1, 2 and 3, right?
Because 1 plus 2 plus
3 is equal to 6.
So there we have it. a, b,
and c are 1, 2 and 3.
So 2 to the a plus 2 to the b
plus 2 to the c is the same
thing as 2 to the 1, plus
2 squared, plus 2 cubed.
That's equal to 2
plus 4 plus 8.
6 plus 8 is equal to 14.
That is choice A.
Next problem, I'll switch
colors for variety.
Problem number 8, in the xy
plane, the center of a circle
has the coordinates
3 comma minus 7.
Let's see if I have
to draw this.
If one endpoint of a diameter of
the circle is minus 2 comma
7-- so this is an endpoint of
the diameter, this is center--
what are the coordinates
of the other
endpoint of this diameter?
Well sure, maybe I'll draw it
for you, just so you get a
sense of all this action
that's going on.
So the center is 3
comma negative 7.
So this is 3-- let me
do it in a different
color-- 3, minus 7.
So this is the center.
This one diameter is
at negative 2, 7.
Actually, I drew this too big.
So this is one endpoint.
So actually the circle
is going to be huge.
Actually let me redraw this
because it's going to be a
huge circle.
I didn't do this
appropriately.
This is the coordinate axes--
I'll draw it big like this.
So the center-- and I'll do it
in a different color-- the
center is at 3, then minus 7.
Right?
And then one endpoint
is at minus 2.
Oh no.
You know what?
I misread the problem.
The other endpoint is
at minus 2, minus 7.
So the other endpoint is
here, minus 2, minus 7.
So it's here.
So I could use this graph.
So the other endpoint
is minus 2, minus 7.
It shows you how important
it is to read
these problems properly.
So if you drew the circle,
the circle actually looks
something like this.
The important thing to realize--
and you actually
didn't even have to draw the
circle-- is that this
diameter, it. this is
the diameter that
they're talking about.
I know I'm drawing it kind of
funny, but this is the point
right here, 3, minus 7.
This is minus 2, minus 7.
So to go from this point to this
point we didn't change
our y-coordinates.
We just changed x.
What did we do?
We went how far back?
We went from x equals 3
to x equals minus 2.
So we went 5 back, right?
So the other endpoint of the
diameter-- we just have to go
5 in this direction.
So if we started x equals
3, we're going to end up
with x equals 8.
Then the y is going to stay the
same because we're moving
horizontally.
So it's 8, negative 7.
That is choice E.
Sorry for misreading it at
first, but that shows it can
happen to the best of us.
No, just kidding.
I'm not even the best of us.
All right, next problem.
9, a regulation for riding a
certain amusement park ride
requires that a child be between
30 inches and 50
inches tall.
So between 30, so height has to
be greater than 30 and less
than 50 inches tall.
Fair enough.
Which of the following
inequalities can be used to
determine whether or not a
child's height satisfies the
regulation for this ride?
OK, so they are essentially just
rewriting this equation
and saying it as
absolute value.
A number line could probably
be useful here.
So if I say-- that's my
number line-- this is
30 and this is 50.
We know, just from this
inequality, that my height can
be anywhere around here.
Whenever I see these absolute
value problems, they're really
picking kind of a median, or the
middle point, between the
two, and they're using the
absolute value to say, well my
distance away from that middle
point can't be more than a
certain amount.
So what you can do is you can
pick the middle point.
If you want to convert this
into an absolute value
equation, you pick
the middle point.
So what's the middle point?
30 plus 50 is 80.
The middle point is 40, right?
I should have been able to do it
in my head because it's 10
away from each other.
So we can say-- instead of
saying that the height has to
be greater than 30 or the height
has to be less than
50-- we could say that the
difference between the height
and 40, and it's absolute
value-- we don't care if the
height is less than 40 or
greater than 40-- but that
absolute distance between
the height and 40 can't
be more than what?
Well, we can't go more than 10
to the positive and we can't
go more than 10 to
the negative.
So the absolute value has
to be less than 10.
That's how you should
[? convert ?]
this.
If you wanted to convert this
to absolute value, how they
tend to do it on the SAT, pick
the average point and then
figure out how far can you
vary from the average?
The average point was 40, and
you can vary at most 10.
So the difference between
the height and 40 has to
be less than 10.
This could also have been
written as 40 minus h
is less than 10.
But the choice is h minus
40 is less than 10, and
that is choice D.
Problem 10, a right, circular
cylinder with radius 5 and
height 4 has volume V.
In terms of V-- oh
look at that.
OK.
So a right, circular cylinder,
so it looks like this.
That's the base.
That's the top of
the cylinder.
Then you have a line like that
and you have a line like that.
What are they telling us?
They're telling us
it's radius 5.
So this distance is 5,
radius 5, height 4.
The volume is V.
OK, so the volume is V.
So what does V equal?
So V is equal to-- you just
have to figure out
the area of the space.
Actually I have a minute left.
So I'm going to do problem
number 10 in the next video so
as to not rush